شكرا للزميل نايف مشاهدي الكرام اسعد الله
اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه التي نخصص معظمها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان نبدا بابرز
العناوين
الامم المتحده تعلن نزوح اكثر من 70 الف
شخص الى خارج السودان وتحذر من وصول العدد
الى 800 الف
وقوات الدعم السريع تتهم الجيش باستخدام
المستشفيات في المعارك والجيش يؤكد ان
الدعم السريع يروع المواطنين
المبعوث الامامي الى السودان يعلن موافقه
طرفي الصراع على ارسال مندوبين للتفاوض
وفي هذه الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
مئات الالاف من المتظاهرين في شوارع فرنسا
احتجاجا على قانون التقاعد واشتباكات مع
الشرطه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الهدوء النسبيه الذي فرضته الهدى
السابقه في السودان لا يبدو انه سيتكرر في
هذه الهدنه ففي الخرطوم بحري واحياء
مختلفه من الخرطوم ارتفعت وتيره
الاشتباكات بين الجانبين مع تصاعد اعمده
الدخان في مشهد يشبه الايام الاولى
للاشتباكات وتقول قوات الدعم السريع ان
الجيش يواصل اختراق الهدنه فيما يؤكد
الجيش انه سيتصدى لمخطط خطف البلاد
ووسط الاتهامات المتبادله تؤكد الامم
المتحده وجود بادره امل لانهاء هذه
الاشتباكات عبر ارسال الجانبين مندوبين من
اجل التفاوض ولكن الى ان يجلس الجانبان
على الطاوله تتعقد الاوضاع المعيشيه
بالنسبه للسودانيين الذين اصبحت اصوات
اطلاق الرصاص بالنسبه اليهم امرا طبيعيا
لازم اشتغل يعني في في الظروف لازم اشتغل
عشان اقدر اكل السلع في زياده يعني اي
حاجه زايده لازم انا اشتغل
زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقف لانه البلد ما امنه
ما بقدر طبعا على الوضع بقى صعب هنشوف بقى
دارينا الشعبي طبعا ما بيعرفوه ولا
لازم واحد تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد
ما حبابه والخوف ما منه فايده
اللاجئين في الامم المتحده توقعاتي بفراري
ما يفوق 800 الف شخص من السودان اثراء
النزاع في البلاد كما اضاف المسؤول ان
ثلاثه وسبعين الف شخص فرو متجهين الى دول
الجوار
وفي السياق ذاته عبر منسق الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه عن مخاوفه من امتداد
ازمه السودان الى دول الجوار واعلن المنسق
ان الوضع الانساني في البلاد يتجه الى نحو
كارثي وانا شحنه من الادويه عالقه على
الحدود ولم تدخل السودان
هذا واتهم الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني
بتحويل مستشفى السلاح الطبي بام درمان الى
منصه للقصف المدفعي واشار في بيان الله
الى ان القصف المدفعي العشوائي من مستشفى
السلاح الطبي ادى لمقتل واصابه كوادر طبيه
بحسب تاكيدات الدعم السريع واضاف ايضا ان
طيران الجيش لا يزال يحلق في سماء الخرطوم
ويقصف احياء سكنيه
وكان الجيش السوداني قد اكد في بيان الله
ان قوات الدعم السريع حشدت اكثر من 65 الف
عنصر والفين مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل
الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع
التصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان
الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال من
ان يخفض قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى
النصف ومضيفا انه تم احباطه عده تحركات
لتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه
من اتجاه الغرب الى الخرطوم
وفي المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع لقطات
فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى القصر
الجمهوري وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت قوات
الدعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على القصر
الجمهوري ومحيطه في الخرطوم بالاضافه الى
مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان
كما اكد احد قاده الدعم السريعه ان
سيطرتهم على القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن
مساعد دعم السريع للحفاظ على ثروات الشعب
السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا
نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب المسلح
بان هذا العمل الذي زجت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين يسولوا على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب
السوداني تواجد قوات الدعم السريع في داخل
القصر وفي كل ولايه الخرطوم القرض الاساسي
منه الحفاظ على سلطه الشعب
هذا وقال المبعوث الاممي الى السودان ان
طرفي الصراع وفقاعه على ارساله مندوبين
للتفاوض بين الجانبين واضاف بيرست في حديث
لوكاله السوشال ان المحادثات ستعقد على
الارجح في السعوديه
المبعوث الامامي قال ان التفاوض سيركز في
المقام الاول على ترسيخ وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل مستمر وموثوق مع وضع فكره انشاء اليه
لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار تضم مراقبين
سودانيين واجانب
وفي تصريحات اخرى حول الاوضاع الانسانيه
قال بيرس ان العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه
الخاصه بالامم المتحده تم نهبها مشيرا الى
ان الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثيا
العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه التي كانت
موجوده في المخازن تم نهبها كل المخازن
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ومفوضيه شؤون
اللاجئين في دارفور مركبات وكاله الاغاثه
تعرضت للسرقه مكاتبي ايضا في دارفور تعرضت
للسرقه لم يتم احترام وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل كامل كان الالتزام جزئيا وفي مواقع
دون الاخرى
لمزيد من المتابعه معمل الاندرمان الصحفي
في مكتب العربيه في السودان شهد نادر شهد
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني في
هذه الاوقات شهدي وهل سقطت الهدنه الاخيره
ام لا هذه الهدنه ما تزال صامته
سلاح الجو السوداني مستمر فيها التحليق في
سماء ام درمان من ثلاث ساعات نفذت طلعات
شاهدنا التحليق ومن ثم شاهدنا الادخنه
تتصاعد من مدينه الخرطوم بحري الان ايضا
يعاود التحليق نستمع الى اصوات المضادات
العرضيه من جهه
اليوم كما قرات الدعم السريع التي قالت
بان بان الوحده الطبيه تابعه لها في ضاحيه
شنبات تعرضت الى القصف شهود عيانه شاروا
الى اشتباكات في منطقه شرق النيل التي تقع
شرق مدينه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اللجنه منذ
حتى هذه حتى هذه
اللحظه اليوم في الامس انا افضل منك
نحن نسمعك ولكن الصوت يتقطع يا شهدي تفضل
المعذره ولكن تدرس الشبكه في بعض المناطق
اليوم كما اسلفت اصوات المضادات عدد اصوات
[موسيقى]
ثقيله بشكل متقطع مثل الجنوب
والشر هذه هي المره الثانيه والثالثه هذا
اليوم
هذه
الاداره الاسلحه الامس مقارنه باليوم
الامس اليوم هذا حركه
الامر بعض الشيء
البعدان
يمكن تستمر هذه هذه ولكن
من جديد بشكل دوري
وصاعد بشكل كبير جدا حتى قبل قليل في
مدينه الخرطوم هل ما الذي قصفته طائرات
الجيش يعني هل يمكن تحديد هذه المواقع
في مدينه الخرطوم
الدعم الفلسفي بيان قالت بان موقعها في
الوحده الطبيه سلاح المظلات تعرض لعمليه
قصف كذلك شاهدنا
مصنع احدى المصانع في مدينه
مدينه الخرطوم البحري في هذه الاثناء التي
يتحدث بها معك سلاح الجو الطائره تتبع
لسلاك الجو تحلق في سماء ام درمان وكذلك
اصحاب المضاده لا تنتشر بكثافه
شهدي هل هنالك اي تقدم لاي طرف على الاخر
ولو بالامتار يعني ان صح التعبير في
الساعات الاخيره ام لا يعني خطوط التماس
ما زالت كما هي يعني اشتباكات من خلف خطوط
التماس دون تقدم لاي طرف على اخر
متمسك به المواقع التي
يسيطر عليها
القوات القوات المسلحه هو الان بانها بصدت
لي هجوم من جهه جسر الحلفايه وتقدمت بحسب
بيان الناطق الرسمي للقوات المسلحه فقط
شهيره
ظلت هذه المناوشات مستمره بالامس واول من
امس كان هناك ما يشبه الفيديو النسبي مكه
بشكل
بدرجه معقوله
للاسف شهدي الصوت يتقطع على كل منهم درمان
الصحفي في مكتب العربيه في السودان شهدي
نادر شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
هذا يواجه السودانيون خطر المواجهات
العسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الدائره منذ ثلاثه اسابيع وعلى الرغم من
الاوضاع الامنيه المترديه يضطر الكثير من
المواطنين الى التوجه الى اعمالهم
ووظائفهم المختلفه لاعاله اسرهم في ظل
اوضاع اقتصاديه وانسانيه صعبه
والله انا لازم اشتغل يعني في الظروف دي
بالذات لازم اشتغل عشان اقدر اكله اقدر
اشرب سلع زاد في زياده ويعني اي حاجه
زايده لازم انا اشتغل يعني
زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقف لانه البلد ما امنه
ما في يعني اي حاجه
عده مخابز شرق العاصمه الخرطوم عوده
تدريجيه للعمل وسط قله الموارد وانعدام
الامن الناس بامانه يعني في ناس تعبت كثير
في اطفال
فقدت حياته في اسره الان الحمد لله بدات
تفتح
والامور ماشيه الخير ربنا يصلح الحال وضع
سيء وضع سيء للغايه
لابعد الحدود
طبعا هذه صور مباشره تردنا الان من
الخرطوم حيث اعمده الدخان تتصاعد بكثافه
نتيجه القصف
وبالطبع الغارات الجويه التي
شنتها طائرات الجيش على مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع على كل نستمع
الى الصوت والصوره من المصدر كما تردنا
الان من العاصمه الخرطوم
وفي متابعه لعمليات الاجلاء توافد المئات
من الرعايه ضمن عمليه الاجلاء المستمره
هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
نحن الان هنا في مدينه بورسودان بشرق
السودان سناخذ جوله لنتعرف على واقع هذا
المركز الرئيسي الذي يضم مئات من الاسر
الذي التي بدات في التوافد الى مدينه
بورسودان نبدا بالجهد الشعبي الذي يوازي
هذه الاعداد الكثيفه الان هيئه الموانئ
البحريه ممثله في غرفه الطوارئ عامله على
توفير هذا المستشفى المؤقت وهذه الغرفه
المؤقته للطوارئ للتعامل مع عدد من
الحالات التي قد ترد الى هذه المنطقه
حالات لسوريين وللسودانيين حتى تقدم لهم
الخدمات في هذا المركز الذي انشئ قبل
يومين في هذه المنطقه التي تضم ايضا كما
ذكرنا عددا من السوريين وعدد من اليمنيين
وايضا اضيفت اليهم نسبه اخرى من المقيمين
السودانيين الذين يحاولون ايضا عبر هذا
المركز ان يغادر
هذه المنصه هنا في شرق السودان الى عدد من
الدول عبر من بورسودان
تقريبا حوالي
345 العدد كبير جوا البناء وبرهوا على
الكورنيش الناس تكون في الارض ارامل اطفال
مسنين مرضى احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني
اغلب الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين
اماكن بعيده اغلبنا اتيم من الخرطوم
هذا وقال عبيده الدندراوي نائب المندوب
الدائم لمصر في الجامعه العربيه ان مصر
استقبلت اربعين الف سوداني منذ بدء الازمه
حتى الان الالتزام بالوقفه الفوري والشامل
للقتال فالى الاولويه لمصلحه الشعب
السوداني يجب ان تظهر من خلال مبادره
الاطراف ببذل كافه مساعيها لحقن الدماء
وهو شرط اساسي للعوده للحوار السياسي
الحتمي الذي يمكن من خلاله حل الازمه بشكل
شامل استقبال مصر حتى صباح اليوم ما يقارب
40 الف مواطن سوداني اضافي عبر معبراي
ارقين وقسطل بالحدود المصريه الجنوبيه
هذا هو يواجه ثلث سكان السودان البالغه
عددهم حوالي 45 مليون نسمه ازمه غذاء
متصاعده ماذا فعل مسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي لوصف الوضع
الانساني في البلاد بالكارثه
معاناه على معاناه تجتم على قلوب
السودانيين اما كساد يؤرق محالهم التجاريه
او شبح جوع يلوح في الافق السودان يشكو
ازمه تتراكم عليها ازمات سابقه متداخله
الوضع الانساني كارثي او كما وصفه الامين
العام للامم المتحده بلغ نقطه الانهيار
السودان اسره على السلطه في السودان لا
يعرض مستقبل هذا البلد للخطر فحسب انه
يضيء فتيله يمكن ان ينفجر عبر الحدود
ويسبب معاناه هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه
الى الوراء لعقود
صراع فاقم معاناه المدنيين الساعين وراء
لقمه العيش تقرير اممي سابق اوضح ان ثلث
السكان اصلا كانوا يعيشون على المساعدات
الانسانيه قبل اندلاع الصراع ووفق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يواجه 15 مليون شخص
انعداما حادا في الامن الغذائي وما عندلاع
الصراع باتت ولايات السودان الثمانيه عشره
تحت رحمه مساعدات قد تتوقف بسبب اغلاق
ممرات الاغاثه حيث تمثل دارفور التحدي
الاكبر من الناحيه الانسانيه بحسب
المنظمات الامميه وتليها عده ولايات هي
الاكثر تضررا من النزاع والتدهور
الاقتصادي كالخرطوم وكسلا والنيل الابيض
وجنوب كردفان لا طعام لملايين الاطفال
تصريح سبق صراع السلطه لمسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان ومع
اول مواجهات اندلعت فان ارقام الذين
سينامون جائعين قد تتضاعف محمد السيف
العربيه
ومع استمرار المعارك في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم تزداد الاوضاع المعيشيه سوءا يوما
بعد يوم هذه قصه عائله طرت الى تركي
منزلها بعد انقطاع المياه والكهرباء
والعيش على وجبه طعام واحده في اليوم
من نافذه غرفه صغيره تراقب هبه شوارع
مدينه غاب عنها الامن والسلام منذ اسابيع
خرجت مع عائلتها الصغيره من منزلهم في
الخرطوم بعد انقطاع الماء والكهرباء جراء
القتال
لتستاجر العائله غرفه فوق سطح مبنى في
منطقه اخرى من العاصمه لعلها تجد فيها بعض
الامان وابسط اساسيات الحياه
لكن صوت ضربات مدفعيه والطيران والرصاص
كان مصاحبا لهم كيف لا وهذا هو الحال في
الخرطوم كلها منذ اندلاع الصراع اصوات انا
كل يوم بسمعها
متعبه شديد يعني بخاف على ناس البيت بخاف
على نفسي
بتمتمات ودعوات تصلي والده هبه من اجل
ابنائها ومن اجل وطن غادره الامن
والاستقرار وعمت فيه الفوضى ولا يعرف ما
ينتظره ان شاء الله ربنا يعني يدي العافيه
والناس تبقى كلها طيبه الوضع يرجع لوضع
الطبيعي ونرجع بيوتنا لانه طولنا بالجنه
من بيوتنا الكهرباء قاطعه لحد
الدعامه قاعدين قدام بيتنا
نصلح العمود بتاع الكهرباء طبعا الكهرباء
ما في مويه ما في عشان كذا احنا فرقنا
البيوت
قلقوا العائله الصغيره وخوفها ليس من وابل
القذائف والرصاص فحسب بل تخشى ايضا من
انقطاع الامدادات الغذائيه فلجات الى حياه
الكفاف ما في مواد غذائيه
كل الدكاكين مقفوله والموجوده باسعار
غاليه شديد بنحاول ناكل اكل قدره حد
الكفاف يعني بناكل وجبه عشان تكفينا باقي
المواد الموجوده لليوم اللي بعديه ولانه
ما معروف قصه من بين الاف القصص لاسر
تكافح في الخرطوم وتبحث عن ابسط حقوقها حق
العيش في سلم وسكينه وسلام وربنا يصلح
الحال ويرجعها على السودان احسن من اول
بكثير ملوك الشيخ العربيه
من كسل ينضم اليه الان جري من هو مدير
الاعلام لدى اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
في السودان سيد جيرمن اهلا وسهلا بك اي
تقييم يمكن اعطائه للاوضاع الانسانيه
والحياتيه في السودان مع دخول المواجهات
الاسبوع الثالث تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم
سيد جيرمن
عملا الى الجانب الهلال الاحمر السوداني
وعندما تحدثوا عن الاوضاع الانسانيه فان
الوضع سيء جدا
وهنا عليك
كوارثه كبيره جدا والاولويه القصوى
بالنسبه لنا هي القطعه الصحيه المستشفيات
الى الان ليس بها الكهرباء او المياه وغير
قادره على العمل
فهم بحاجه الى مساعداته كبيره جدا وعلينا
ان نبدا بتقديم الدعم للمستشفيات خاصه من
خلال توفير المياه والكهرباء وكذلك توفير
اللقاحات طيب ما الذي يمكنكم تقديمه في
هذا الاطار يعني انت تحدثت عن الاحتياجات
ولكن هل يمكنكم تقديم اي مساعده في هذا
الاطار سيد جيرمن ام لا يعني لا يمكن
تقديمها في هذه الاوقات او لا يمكن ارسال
هذه المساعدات حتى لو توفرت
الاحد
اللي جاءتنا الشحنه
وصلتي الى السودان
وهذه هي اول الشحنه من المواد الطبيه
المؤقته للارواح والان بدانا
بالعمل اللي يندق لها من بورتال السوداني
الى الخرطوم ودار فورد المدن والمدن
المتاثره بالقتال هذه هي الشحنه الاولى
كما اتوقع شحنه ثانيه في الايام المقبله
وكذلك ان نترقب وصول الافراد لتقديمي
المساعده في استجابتنا هنا في السودان
الان نحن
تقريبا وصلنا الى الوضع الذي يمكننا من
التزويد المستشفيات بالمساعدات الطبيه
وكذلك المتطوعين من الهلال الاحمر
السودانيه الذين يقدمون المساعده للجرحى
والمصابين ولكننا بحاجه الى ضمانات امنيه
من الاطراف المتقاتله الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لكي
اتمكن موظفونها وقوافلنا من الانتقال او
الوصول الى المناطق المتاثره بالقتال
لتزويد تلك المعدات الطبيه الى المستشفيات
سيد جري من
مما تصل الى
من هنالك من يتولى توزيعها وما الضامن بان
الاطراف المتنازعه لن تسيطر على هذه
المساعدات لمصالحها
الصليب الاحمر سيكون مسؤولا عن توزيع هذه
المواد الى المستشفيات
وهذا المستشفيات هي المسؤوله عن توفير
عنايه الصحيه فمسؤوليه
كل هذا العمل سيبقى بين يدي اللجنه
الدوليه الى الصليب الاحمر ولكن من اجل
البدي بتنديد وتطبيقات العمل فنحن بحاجه
الى ضمانات امنيه من الاطراف
المتقاتله سبق وان
اخبرناهم
وطلبنا منهم تسهيل
عمل المنظمات الانسانيه والكوادر الطبيه
ونعمل من انهم سيسهلون عملنا لكي نتمكن من
تقديم المساعدات الى كل من هم بحاجه اليها
سيد
السودان تحديدا مستشفيات الخرطوم بشكل
عاجل
العديد من المستشفيات في الخرطوم واغلبها
اليوم لا تعمل ولاسباب مختلفه السبب الاول
هو الافتقار الى الادويه كما ذكرت المعدات
الطبيه
كما ان العديد من المستشفيات ليس لديها
المياه او الكهرباء كما هو الحال في
المناطق العديده من الخرطوم
وسبب الرئيسي لان محطات المياه والكهرباء
والبنى التحتيه المسؤوله عن توفير المياه
والكهرباء في المدن
هي بحاجه الى الصيانه والمسؤولون عن
صيانتها غادروا الخرطوم والبعض منهم
غير قادر على الذهاب من المنزل الى اماكن
العمل فهم ايضا بحاجه الى ضمانات امنيه
لكي يتناقلوا بحريه وامان داخل المدن من
اجل القيام باعمالهم
لانهم لم يقم باعمالهم ولم تكن هنالك
صيانه لشبكات المياه والكهرباء وهذه البنت
التحتيه ففي الختام المدينه سوف تفتقر الى
المياه والكهرباء هكذا هو الحال مع
المستشفيات
وحتى الكوادر الطبيه هم ايضا بحاجه الى
التحرك والانتقال منازلهم ذهابا الى
المستشفيات الاقلام بعملهم والعوده الى
منازلهم فهم ايضا بحاجه لضمانات امنيه
كما ترون فهم المهم جدا للاطراف المقاتله
ان تساعد على تسهيل الحركه الامنه للفرق
الطبيه في الخرطوم وكافه المدن المتاثره
بالقتال
من اكثر من منظمه انسانيه حذرت او التخوفت
من امكانيه انتشار الكوليرا والملاريا هل
لديكم نفس هذه المخاوف وهل سجلت اي حالات
وفق متابعتكم
الى الان لم تردنا اي معلومات عن اي
اصابات في الكوليرا في الخرطوم والمدن
الاخرى ولكن التخوف هو ان مثل هذه
الاوبوياء قد تظهر وتبرز في الايام
المقبله اذا لم نقم بعملنا
لان السكان هنا ليس لدي امكانيه الحصول
على المياه النقيه او الصالحه للشرب فمثل
هذه الاوبئه مثل الكوليرا يمكن ان تنتشر
في المدن مثل الخرطوم
فمنهم جدا للسلطات والاطراف المقاتله ان
تضمن
استمرار عملي محطات المياه وكافه البنى
التحتيه المزوده للمياه والكهرباء ان تكون
محميه وان
تعمل وان يتمكن كافه الموظفين من الذهاب
الى اعمالهم بامان لانهم اذا لم يقموا
بعمليه الصيانه على البنى التحتيه الخاصه
الكهرباء
بالتاكيد ستكون اوضاع مزريه بالنسبه الى
القطاع الصيدلي سيد
جريمه الصيدليات مقفله
الصيدليات ليس بوسيها ان تعمل بالوضع
الطبيعي لانهم بحاجه الى الادويه
من المزودين
فكل شيء فيما يخص حركه
المنتجات والبشر في الخرطوم لا يعمل بشكل
طبيعي هذا هو الوضع بشكل اساسي من كسل جري
من مدير الاعلام لدى اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
وفي يوم درمان قرر الالاف من السودانيين
نزوحا من مناطقهم هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
فيما يتجه كثيرون الى من خلال حافلات لنقل
الركاب باتت تكلفتها اغلى من المعتاد بسبب
نقص الوقود ويقول الاهالي في ام درمان ان
العائلات تتجه الى مواقف الحافلات سيرا
على الاقدام بسبب عدم توفر وسائل للنقل مع
استمرار الاشتباكات المسلحه
الرغم من الخرطوم للولايات فبرضه يعني
الحاجه صعبه شديد يعني اول كلمه ماجد خاش
الشعبي لقيت دفار بعشره
دفار باقل تذكره للبيض بعشر فما بالك يعني
باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
الباصات حتكون كيف
نوجهها الولايات حاليا يعني الباصات كلها
بتمشي بورسودان 12 13 مليار لو بنفس
الحساب
يصل الاف سودانيين الفرين الى الحدود
المصريه عن طريق منفذ قسطل البري لتكون
مدينه ابو سمبل اولى محطات استقبالهم
اهالي المدينه حرصوا على تقديم كافه انواع
المساعده للنازحين الهاربين من الاشتباكات
الداميه في بلادهم
عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من بعد قسط البري الوجوه المرهقه من عناء
الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع استقبال
اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود المصريه
الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين ما تيسر
من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي السودان قبل
استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه اسوان احنا طبعا
لازم نقف جنب شقاءنا السودانيين في الازمه
اللي هم فيها واحنا عملنا المبادره دي مع
شباب القريه عندنا وحسين انه احنا اهل
البلد يعني يعني الخدمه اللي قدموها لنا
ما حسستني انه مازلنا في السودان يعني بعض
القادمين لا يملكون الاموال اللازمه
لاستكمال الرحله احدى المجموعات النازحه
توجهت الى وسط المدينه لتفاجا برد فعل
الاهالي الذين قاموا بجمع المساعدات
المطلوبه
والله انا يعني سم ده سمبل وانا ما نسموه
سنابل
الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم والله
كل خير يعني وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونه للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء تامين شامل
سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو لقينا برضو
مساعدات من جهات تانيه ففضل الله محدش
مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعفاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنت الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه من جده مع
من هناك مراسل العربيه سلطان السلامي
سلطان اهلا وسهلا بك جديد مشهد الاجلاء
وابرز مشاهداتك في هذه الاوقات سلطان
اهلا بك اهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه الان وصلت سفينه جلاله الملك ابها
هذه السفينه التي على متنها عدد كبير من
الرعايه كما يظهر لنا امامكم على الصوره
يبدا القوات البحريه السعوديه بتجهيز
السلم الخاص لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى يستطيعوا
النزول على ارض قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده نتحدث انه تم اجلال هؤلاء الرعايه
من ميناء بورت السودان الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في جده في رحله استغرقت
قرابه عشر ساعات نتحدث انه 200 واثنى عشر
راكبا على متن هذه السفينه من 12 جنسيه
اختلفت الجنسيات وتنوعت بين افغانستان
وبين السودان وبين الفلبين والجزر القمر
وسريلانكا وكذلك اوكرانيا ومن بريطانيا
وسوريا وامريكا وكذلك من مدغشقر نتحدث انه
هذه السفينه 41 مواطن سعودي وكذلك نتحدث
عن وجود
سبعه اشخاص من رعايه اوكرانيا تم اجلائهم
من ميناء بورت سودان الى مقاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه وهذه الرحله رقم 14 منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلاء نتحدث عن وجود اثنى عشر
اثني عشر
سفينه بحريه السعوديه تابع القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه وكذلك نتحدث عن
السفينتين مدنيه وتسمى بسفينه امان التي
قامت خلال يومين الماضيه بنقل عدد كبير من
الرعايه طوال منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء كان
قد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اعداد من تم اجلائهم من السودان الى جده
تحديدا عبر ميناء جد الاسلامي وعبر
القاعده الجويه وكذلك عبر قاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه مع هذه الرحله بلغ عددهم
5409 عشره شخص وتنوعت الجنسيات وتنوعت
كذلك الاعمار ايضا نتحدث عن اكثر من 100
او ينتبون لاكثر من 100 من ضمنهم مواطنين
سعوديين وعربيين ومن الخليج وكذلك من
اوروبا ومن فريق ومن افريقيا واختلفت
الجنسيات كما ذكرنا من مئه جنسيه على متن
هذه السفينه هنالك خمسه حالات طبيه واحده
منها سوف يتم نقلها الى اقرب مستشفى من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ليتم بتقديم
العلاج اللازم لها علامه هذه السفينه فرق
الطبيه لتقديم الاسعافات الاوليه والتعامل
مع الحالات الصحيه التي تم اجلائها من
ميناء بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه قبل وصول هذه السفينه تواجد عدد
كبير من السفراء والقناصل لهؤلاء الرعايه
لاستقبالهم وكذلك وجود عدد من الممثلي
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وعدم القطاعات
الامنيه لاستقبال هؤلاء الرعايه وانهاء
كافه اجراءات دخولهم الى اراضي السعوديه
ومنحهم تاشيره دخول لمده شهر قامت بمنحها
وسوف تقوم بمنحها من قبل بمنحها من قبل
المديريه
للجوازات تاشيره استثنائيه لهؤلاء الرعايه
نظرا للظرف الانسان الذي اهم عليه ايضا
نتحدث انه طوال هذه الرحله خدمات كبيره
تقدم لهؤلاء الرعايه من ضمنها توفير غرف
النوم خاصه لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك توفير
الاعاشه وكافه الخدمات اللوجستيه والصحيه
لهؤلاء الرعايه في ظل الظروف الصعبه التي
عاشوا تفاصيلها طوال الايام الماضيه هنالك
في السودان في الخرطوم تحديدا او حتى في
الولايات التابعه للخرطوم في ظل اشتباكات
المسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع وبين الجيش
السوداني دقائق محدوده وبسيطه وسوف يتم
تركيب هذا السلم وانزال هؤلاء الرعايه
ونقلهم عبر اسطول من الحافلات الى مقرات
سكن قامت بتخصيصها السلطات السعوديه
سلطان هل من معلومات عن اي رحلات بحريه
مجدوله في 48 ساعه المقبله
ستستقبلها قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده المعلومات
بالفعل لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء مستمره من
السودان جوا وبحرا لتحدثنا الى قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او عبر ميناء جدا اسلامي او
حتى كذلك عبر قاعده او الجسر الجوي الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده من
المتوقع وصول غدا سفينه امانه السفينه
التجاريه المدنيه السعوديه وعلى متنها
اعداد تلامس الالفين شخص باختلاف جنسياتهم
لا سيما من هذه السفن المدنيه تستطيع
استيعاب اكبر الاعداد من الرعايه الذين
سوف يتم اجلائهم من من بورت السودان الى
جده هذه السفره البحريه التابع للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه تستطيع استيعاب
اعداد محدوده نظرا انه هذه السفينه مخصصه
للعمليات العسكريه وغيرها لكن صخره
السلطات السعوديه والقوات البحريه
السعوديه كافه السفر البحريه والمدنيه
لاجلاها هؤلاء الرعايه بشكل مستمر منذ بدء
النزاعات هنالك في السودان من ميناء
بورسودان نقلا قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه
وقاعه الملك عبد الله الجويه وكذلك عبر
ميناء جده الاسلامي نؤكد من عمليات اللجنه
مستمره كما اعلن او صرح لنا العميد التركي
المالكي المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الدفاع
يوم امس للعربيه والحدث بان عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره من قبل الحكومه السعوديه
للرعايه باختلاف جنسيتهم واعمارهم وفئاتهم
الى مدينه جده بحسب الوضع الراهن في
السودان نشاهد الان علامه او على سطحه على
متن هذه السفينه الرعايه يستعدون للنزول
الى قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه نتحدث عن
جنسيات متعدده
وفق معلوماتك اذا سمحت لي كم كم تستغرق
الرحله من الوقت يعني
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بشكل اجمالي
وهل يعني الرحله من السفينه الى سفينه
تختلف من حيث الوقت ام لا
بالفعل السفن البحريه التابع للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه تستغرق قرابه من
العشر ساعات الى 12 ساعه من ميناء بورت
سودان وصولا الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
فيما يتعلق بالسفر المدنيه الضخمه
والكبيره قد تاخذ وقت اطول سيما العدد
العدد اكبر وكذلك سفينه ضخمه فقد تستغرق
وقت اطول لفئه لعمليات النقل من ميناء
بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده ايضا نشير ان عمليات الاجلاب لا تزال
مستمره بشكل ملحوظ منذ بدل منذ بدل اسمه
هنالك في السودان لكن الخدمات المقدمه اذا
اشرنا اليها علامتنا هذه السفينه نحن قد
قمنا بمرافقه احدى السفن البحريه السعوديه
خلال اليومين الماضيه واستغرقت قرابه
العشر ساعات وتم تقديم كافه الخدمات
اللوجستيه والصحيه والطبيبيه لهؤلاء
الرعايه
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده مراسل
العربي سلطان السلمي شكرا جزيلا لك سلطان
على كل هذه المتابعه
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني هو والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كتير هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس كتير معلقه
نحمد الله سبحانه والشكر لاهل المملكه هل
هذا الاستقبال
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات